في مركز ولاية أوهايو للاضطرابات المعرفية والذاكرة ،
مرحبًا الدكتور دوغلاس شاري ،
بدأ في ملاحظة شيء ما في
علاج مرضاه كنا نفقد
القارب ولم نكن نحدد الأشخاص
مبكرًا بما يكفي
كلما تم التشخيص مبكرًا ، كلما أسرع العلاج ، يكون مفتاح
إبطاء التدهور المعرفي لهذا السبب
طور شاري اختبار حكيم ، والفرق الرئيسي
بين هذا الاختبار وغيره
هو أنه يمكن إجراء الاختبارات
في المنزل عند ظهور أول علامة
على ضعف الذاكرة ، لذلك يمكن
مراقبة التغييرات بمرور الوقت بينما لا يتم
تشخيص مرض الزهايمر.  يساعد
في تحديد الأعراض المبكرة ، وهو
المؤلف الرئيسي لدراسة نشرت في
مجلة أبحاث الزهايمر وعلاجها ،
حيث تابعت أكثر من 600 مريض على مدار
ثماني سنوات ، ويبدو أنه يلتقط
الأشخاص الذين سيصابون في النهاية
بالخرف قبل ستة أشهر على الأقل
من معظمهم.  اختبار نموذجي
هناك ، الأمر متروك للطبيب لإجراء
التشخيص بناءً على التغييرات المعرفية في
تاريخ العائلة ولكن أنا  تحديد
تطور محتمل للخرف يمكن أن
يسمح بعلاج مبكر ، آمل في
هذا الاختبار أن يتم تشخيص المزيد من الأشخاص
وعلاجهم بشكل
مناسب للحظة الصحية.